i'd want to get you caught up on
something
we talked about at the start of the week
fox news
comedy show and i'm using that term
very loosely fox news comedy show
gutfeld
debuted on monday night and it's maybe
the least funny comedy show that i've
ever seen
and one of the questions i asked on
monday was why does right wing comedy
not work many of you weighed in and i'm
going to have
some of your thoughts in a couple of
minutes somehow
in the first week the show has gotten
even less funny check out a couple of
these clips from last night's episode
here's i th these terms it's
they're of questionable meaning here is
a sketch
or a skit about how if the master's golf
tournament
is racist then anything with the word
master is therefore racist take a look
somehow this voter id law was racist
meanwhile
they still have the masters right yeah
it's called the masters
[Laughter]
if master bedrooms are racist the
masters are racist
masturbation is racist master chef
is racist what is masturbation no i
don't know is your dad watching oh
your dad's in the audience very good joe
i am dying to find out what's in your
brain
who thinks that's funny the only funny
thing about it
is i can't really i can't think of
anything that's really funny about it
now
one of the big controversies around the
masters has actually been that augusta
national golf club
doesn't allow women and then that's
getting mixed up with the georgia voter
law stuff
uh which are you know racially
suppressive
uh uh along along racial lines the jokes
don't even make sense never mind being
funny
for the third night in a row they did
another segment about cnn
supposedly being obsessed with racism
three nights running the exact same
joke even though i don't even know what
the joke is vacation isn't the goal
conflict is and once you see this
framework it shows up
everywhere i mean take a look at what's
on cnn right now
grandma's butterscotch
maybe the bear does have a point there
the bear is a racist
he is a racist so three nights in a row
with that one i don't know if they can't
come come up with anything better or
they think that that one's really
working it's not clear
if it was a good joke i could maybe see
going with it like go with what works
this is not a joke that's working and i
also am wondering like is there really a
studio audience or is the laughter just
employees who are hanging out in the
room because it sounds very very sparse
like it's all very strange
every detail if you were to tr if you
were trying
to make a satire of right wingers doing
a comedy show
this is what a saturday night live skit
about
right wing comedy shows would look like
but this is actually the show
so now on to your comments i asked on
monday
why can't right wingers do comedy why
doesn't it work
and i got a bunch of interesting
responses many of you wrote to me and
said
you know david the the reason right you
said sir
the reason right wing comedy doesn't
work is because right wingers
want to watch news channels and get
angry
not watch news channels and laugh i
think there's probably something to that
to some degree another idea is that
right wingers become motivated and
activated by disinformation that's
presented as fact
so when they have disinformation
presented as comedy
they're not sure like are we supposed to
laugh are we supposed to take it
seriously are we supposed to rant in all
caps on twitter like what are we
supposed to do as a result of this
a bunch of people made some pretty
aggressive comments about intelligence
saying you know if you're dumb enough to
fall
for what fox news reports as news
you probably don't have the intelligence
to understand comedy or satire or parody
and it's the wrong audience in other
words the idea that an appreciation of
humor requires a level of intelligence
that your average fox news viewer lacks
that's a very aggressive statement for
sure uh but maybe there's something to
it you tell me
one person wrote in and said the problem
is that the jokes are both
lazy but too mean-spirited
they you really need them to be clever
and slightly mean-spirited like they're
not calibrated correctly
one viewer suggested that the problem is
that it is humor
but it's basically an adult version of
the high school bullies making fun of
the one disabled kid or the one black
kid
so it just comes off as like crass and
inappropriate rather than funny
that's a pretty interesting analogy
actually there may be something to that
and then last thing and there's a common
thread to all of these
someone wrote to me and suggested
they're not really doing satire
they're expressing their the same
contempt that they express
all the time in a way that they hope
will get people to laugh
and it just doesn't work i think there's
something to all of these critiques
for sure let me know why you think
this right-wing comedy idea is not
working let me know how long you think
this show will last as i told you on
monday the half-hour news hour which was
the last attempt at comedy by fox news
i it lasted 17 episodes i don't remember
if that was a weekly show or a daily
show
17 episodes on a weekly show is 17 weeks
17 episodes on a weeknight show is like
three and a half weeks i don't know
but tell me how long you think the
gutfeld show looks like it's going to
last
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford i
asked them to be a sponsor because they
are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden
underneath the buttons which actually
prevents the chest from looking weird
and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt
in a specific way that makes your upper
body look a lot better it's just a much
nicer and more stylish fit than you get
from other shirts
and they hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout